we're all looking at this question is
unconscious up like a Christmas tree but
let's say why let's back up lyrics to me
most people are photos on the right a
negative one there's one are we happy
with anyone yeah yes is there anyone
you'd like to add something good I'm
happy with that true but I think it
could be a little better hazel ok so i
asked you to Seoul right when you have
to solve something there's no I'm not
going to say weirdness there's something
to start with pastry is a perennial
right I didn't know what pruner will
means anyway pretty yeah reckoning it's
a letter in placement number in fact
anything in places for the number you
could say you know instead of 3x plus 4
you could have gone three carries plus
forth that would have been flying is in
place of a number and hopefully [ __ ] you
have you know about the reason why is
because as well you guys know a big not
anywhere with those are all the way back
when you start learning about language
adjective verb cetera pronouns of words
like me I Tim they are words that you
put in place off now write something in
place of a noun so printable is
something anything in place when you're
okay Zapata group but of course this
negative 1 is in place of something
specific namely yes okay so I'm happy
negative on this is a pencil how about
this one I see 49 minutes squared happy
not happy yeah I'm okay with that are
you can see thankfully we also had on a
little bit of working half free 411 3
plus 11 times better what is your top 11
14 Harper's out is 7 7 squared is 49
okay cool right now which is having a
brief discussion about this shape now
one of the things i pointed out to a few
of you is it i didn't say how you had to
work out the area i just did find it
okay how would you go about calculating
the size of the space inside here so i
wanted to suggest yeah
hi okay so if you think about it in
terms of this question over here its
entropy diem you can use what you know
about repeating here as well but you
still need to back up a little bit
because how did you know this wasn't
reprieve you I didn't tell you which
medium so how do we know yeah we read
online okay so usually we indicate
parallel lines with an error and these
aunties are parallel but I haven't put
the arrow so how did you know they were
parallel are you okay so i have right
angles but so what why would write
anything anything about these one big
curl the chin parallel line right angles
you want to pair right angles right what
does that mean they add up to do some at
the pair of running women goodnight
reads right do you know anything about
180 degrees and parallel parallel was
all a dream see it is also the words
walk she was just asleep the hotel yo in
Turkey I thank you co interior angles
could again coming here like they're
both on the inside these are towards
your angles that add up to 180 degrees
by the real strange with that after
effects supplementary effect that means
they're parallel and stuffing the turkey
good now we're ready to use a refund say
will okay if you want to find out the
area trapezium you can't really use this
number even though it has to do with the
hype why not yeah it's not straight up
right so in fact what we want is this
length lomas year so someone sent
spinning through yet so one suggests how
I can draw that finding that link over
there jquery ok pi parish is going to
get involved however i'm a bit of a
little bit of a problem with using
photography because i don't see any
range so what i'm going to do some
drizzle
great one by drawing a line to make this
triangle fantastic shall not add a
construction ovg Ark and remember i said
why did you walk in you draw a diagram
if you need a diagram i would suggest
all one kind of need a diagram for this
because otherwise how can you say what
you're doing here if you drop that line
down you get running with that someone
total to do next yeah spirals the baby
ok so this space over here right the
whole thing in 16 I'm going to know what
nothing and triangle so how do i get to
bear wear a tiara you suppose the way
the 12 line okay so I've got eight over
here do you agree with that because what
shape is this on my left hand side with
if it happens to be a square exactly
right though actually sorry I take that
back it's not quite where is it I mean a
book 3 squared up in a fire at the
moment I know it's a rectangle it may
well end up being a square I don't think
it is in this case doesn't see it as
eight what's this also named and now
we're ready to use high standards okay
so can someone tell me a live one here
that's the height right I think it's six
think it sticks because six eight ten
that's double of three four five which
is the most common set a number to get
in a month impression ok so now you're
ready to tell me what the area is one
scary offices I think it's going to be a
half a plus B will get to the extra
second time to cool because that was a
highly just worked out a half of six is
three three times with this when he
fought so that gives us cool good job
yeah
the pieces hold on okay